last time you saw my family it's been
like man's been like
man I don't even remember like two and a
half years yeah I'm like three years ago
my grandparents died
my my parents told me you know if you
don't come back for their funeral then
you don't need to come back at all I
guess you know it's like crap like that
man that I just don't know if they want
me back man
you know I guess that's how I think
about I don't know if they want me back
why wouldn't they want you back I guess
I just spent years and years convincing
them that they were there was stupid for
not supporting me out here and I
not letting me do my thing my thing and
so I feel like if I go back now alls I'm
going to here for the rest of my life as
I told you so and I'm just going to have
that like voice that like nas at you
every freaking moment of your life and
that's that's that voice man that voice
it just doesn't let me quit
you